[Música]
durante tres horas de acalorado debate
los candidatos en la presidencia
francesa discutieron sobre los
principales temas de la agenda de cara
al balotaje del domingo el presidente
manuel mccomb atacó a ma jin lo penal a
asegurar que rusia su banquero en
referencia a un préstamo que su partido
agrupación nacional obtuvo de un banco
ruso checo que según el mandatario aún
no se ha devuelto lo pensé defendió
indicando que se trata de afirmaciones
deshonestas analizamos en esta emisión
altos negociadores ucranianos dijeron
que están listos para mantener
conversaciones especiales en la asediada
ciudad de mariupol sin condiciones esto
mientras que los soldados ucranianos se
enfrentan a los continuos bombardeos del
kremlin tras su ultimátum presidente
volodymyr selenski pidió más ayuda
internacional
las calles de río de janeiro vuelven a
llenarse de color y música con el inicio
del famoso carnaval que tuvo que ser
suspendido durante dos años la causa de
la pandemia de kobe 19 las mundialmente
famosas escuelas de samba vuelven a la
acción para sus primeros desfiles en el
conocido sambódromo vamos hasta allí en
esta emisión
buenas noches para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24 y
valentina torres sánchez damos inicio en
francia los dos candidatos al palacio
del elíseo se enfrentaron durante casi
tres horas en televisión pública en el
debate de cara del balotaje del domingo
el mandatario francés emmanuel marco no
perdió tiempo y atacó a su rival de
extrema derecha ma jing lu peng
asegurando que depende de vladimir putin
asimismo señaló que rusia es su banquero
esto en referencia a un préstamo que
agrupación nacional el partido del 'open
pidió para la campaña de 2014 a un banco
ruso checo que aún está pagando lópez
señaló que sólo debe ese dinero y que
toma tiempo saldar las deudas los
candidatos también se enfrentaron en
temas como el poder adquisitivo la salud
las pensiones el costo de vida las
políticas climáticas y energéticas
veamos el enfrentamiento respecto a
rusia
hablé de un punto preciso que tiene que
ver con el financiamiento de su partido
lo que dije es falso señor arpey
sí señor marco es falso y es bastante de
suelo público entonces
yo me veo obligada a sacar este préstamo
en el extranjero si todo el mundo del
odio sabe eso lo sabe todo el mundo fui
a buscar el préstamo en el exterior
porque ningún banco francés me quiso
conceder un préstamo en ese momento eso
fue tan escandaloso que usted
hablo de crear un banco de la democracia
pero nunca lo hizo porque no termino con
este proyecto del banco de la democracia
usted sabía que ese banco de la
democracia llenaría un déficit
democrático de los bancos que parecían
escoger a sus partidos políticos hoy de
hecho durante las elecciones pueden
elegir a los candidatos que podéis que
querían abortar o no señor man hawk y si
decide algo préstamos en 2015 señor paro
como usted está haciendo
candidatos en esta elección que
defienden ideas cercanas como señores de
nuevo no fueron a buscar préstamos en
hungría o en rusia y también quiero
decirle señor bajo que millones de
franceses que en los últimos cinco años
fueron a solicitar préstamos en los
bancos franceses para comprar carros o
casas
a bancos franceses para pagar sus
bancos
esta diferencia para analizar este tenso
encuentro entre más en lepe y emanuel
macondo leonor carbap ella es abogada y
analista con especialidad en relaciones
internacionales
bienvenida a france 24 para no hablar de
un ganador y un perdedor desde su
perspectiva quién se mostró más seguro y
conocedor de lo que en estos momentos
centra la atención de los franceses
muy buenas noches gracias por invitarme
bueno realmente yo creo que el debate
fue mucho menos tenso que hace cinco
años pero que claramente se vio un
dominio de los temas que le importan más
a los franceses por parte de manuel
manjón en varias ocasiones más en el
open tuvo que revisar sus cifras tuvo
que volver tuvo que éxito un poco en sus
respuestas o sea que yo realmente creo
que ahí no cabe la menor duda bueno y en
un debate como éste realmente puede
inclinar la balanza a favor de uno de
los candidatos realmente sirve para
conquistar a los indecisos
sí bueno eso es lo que se temía mucho
antes de que empezara el debate qué
imagen lo peleen mucho más preparada que
hace cinco años fuera mucho más
convincente ella también ha beneficiado
de una estabilización por parte del
candidato de extrema derecha desde muy
haciéndola ver a ella como una un
personaje un poco más o menos digamos de
extrema derecha entonces lo que se temía
era que este debate pudiera hacer
cambiar la balanza pero yo creo que toca
ser mi opinión personal que no fue el
caso que al final del debate los dos
candidatos enseñaron sus verdaderas
caras más european volvió a sus temas de
predilección que son la inmigración la
inseguridad y todo eso realmente les
permite a los franceses es situarse en
campos ya definidos o sea que no creo
que este debate haya realmente cambiado
el balance de la elección bueno con
estas propuestas que fueron expuestas
hoy de manera bastante directa es
probable que el open logre adoptar los
votos de ixe - de la primera vuelta y
mccann de los demás datos que de alguna
manera pidieron votar por él o dijeron
que ellos votarían por él
bueno el más grande desafío de manejo es
luchar contra los abstencionistas
porque obviamente que el voto de meloso
se divide en una serie de personas que
si van a votar prema en el marco y otros
que ya han indicado que querían
abstenerse lo que si pudiera cambiar con
este debate es que al ver la verdadera
cara de ma jin lo ven al ver que los
temas
digamos clásicos de la extrema derecha
vuelven a estar sobre la mesa esos
electores indecisos pudieran cambiar la
idea y si poner un voto en la urna para
emanuel mejor pero aparte aparte de eso
yo pienso que los los digamos los
votantes que ya tenían pensado dar por
margen lo está en todos los de ese muy
una parte de la derecha digamos más
radical no no no habrá cambiado de idea
sino que está confrontado en sus
opiniones sobre más inglés bernie
eleonora usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en france 24
gracias a usted muy buenas noches ahora
nos enfocamos en la guerra en ucrania la
ofensiva rusa se intensificó en el este
del país en la región del donbass la
ciudad de mariupol sigue asediada por
las tropas rusas que le dieron un nuevo
ultimátum a las tropas ucranianas que
siguieron sin rendirse pero respondieron
que quiere está listo para llevar a cabo
una ronda especial de negociaciones sin
condiciones esto al tiempo que las
autoridades ucranianas informaron que el
acuerdo que se había llegado para para
evacuar a 6000 civiles en la ciudad no
prosperó porque moscú no respetó el cese
el fuego estas fueron las palabras del
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
rumbo móvil sí mismo somos estamos
haciendo más que lo máximo para asegurar
el suministro de armamento para nuestro
ejército todos los días todos nuestros
diplomáticos yo personalmente estamos
utilizando todos los canales oficiales y
no oficiales para esto estamos
trabajando 24 horas al día 7 días a la
semana en esto para acelerar la llegada
de la ayuda militar estoy muy contento
de decir con cautela y optimismo que
nuestros y ha comenzado a comprender
mejor nuestras necesidades a comprender
qué es lo que realmente necesitamos y
cuando lo necesitamos todo esto no lo
necesitamos en una semana en un mes sino
de inmediato ahora mismo cuando rusia
intente reforzar sus avances rights
active su bote soy estar más de 620.000
personas han perdido la vida en brasil
por el coi 19 y esta semana por primera
vez desde el 5 de enero es decir desde
la llegada de la variante o micro nada
de este país el promedio semanal de
muertos bajó de los 100 diarios en medio
de este panorama favorable las calles de
ríos se vuelven a llenar de música y
color con la inauguración del carnaval
previamente valeria saccone corresponsal
de france 24 nos dio más detalles
después de dos años de pandemia vuelve
el carnaval en el sambódromo de río de
janeiro un carnaval fuera de época en
abril en un ferrero nacional llamado
tiradentes que recuerda a un héroe
nacional que ayudó a liberar un estado
llamado minas gerais vuelve un carnaval
largo que va a durar casi dos semanas
porque vamos a tener durante cuatro días
desfiles los primeros dos días del grupo
de oro en las escuelas de acceso que
disputan una plaza en el grupo especial
viernes y sábado las escuelas más
querida las 12 esker y niñas de oro que
van a disputar el título de campeona
después la semana que viene el martes
tendremos la votación y finalmente el
sábado el desfile de las campeonas es
decir la escuela que gana y además las
otras 5 que recibieron las mejores notas
es un carnaval
en la historia de río de janeiro no se
recuerda otra vez en que río de janeiro
tuvo dos carnavales porque
que en febrero las comparsas salieron a
la calle a pesar de la prohibición del
ayuntamiento porque la ola de comida
estaba remitiendo gracias a una
vacunación récord recordamos que el 85%
de la población en brasil está
totalmente vacunado
a ustedes gracias por acompañarnos en
esta jornada informativa feliz noche
para todos
[Música]